so yeah so I'm going to talk to you
about network variation and I guess you
know my groups worked on analyzing
protein interaction networks for a long
time and we've done a lot of work at
counter flow graph theoretic methods for
analyzing networks but we also do a lot
of work thinking about predicting
interactions as well and so today I
really wanted to focus specifically on
the question of trying to assess
computationally to what extent do
protein interactions and networks vary
across organisms and individuals so in
yesterday's panel discussion we talked a
lot about whether thinking about protein
interactions in the cell whether it made
sense to think about them with this nice
graph interpretation and I think it does
but when you want to answer questions
about protein interact interaction
variation or a network variation I think
the task is actually more difficult than
the opposite question of asking whether
interactions are conserved or network
modules are conserved and a lot of that
has to do of course with what's been
measured and the noise and the
measurements and so we know that we have
many interactions that haven't been
observed but this could be because
they've never been measured or this
could be because their errors in the
experimentation and so we're thinking
about how to address this question with
the data we have and so we're going to
think about protein interactions but
we're going to look at them a little bit
more closely and in my group we do a lot
of work relating to protein structure
and so we're going to think about some
of these protein interactions with
respect to the underlying structural
interface that makes these interactions
possible and so I'm going to try to tell
you two stories relating to network
variation one relating to
transcriptional regulatory network
variation and the other relating to
variation across individuals so let me
start with telling you about variation
of regulatory networks across organisms
and this is joint work with shilpa nod
and poly a graduate student in my group
who came from tufts well represented
here as well as Anton Percy Gogh has
been in my group for a while
as a research fellow so actually saw in
the first talk today that you know that
a lot of the changes that we see between
organisms are thought to be due to
changes in gene regulatory networks and
so is observed a long time ago that if
you look at the protein-coding regions
between chip and human that they're very
similar so greater than ninety-nine
percent identical and yet we'd like to
think that we're a little bit different
from from chimps and so is proposed that
it's not differences in protein coding
regions that are responsible for these
phenotypic differences but instead it's
changes the networks and in particular
gene regulatory networks and this has
been verified experimentally in various
model systems many of them in fly
actually where they've shown what
happens when you change pieces of
regulatory networks and you see
differences in morphology or
pigmentation or other such things
so how might transcriptional regulatory
networks change so we all know the basic
paradigm of transcription factors
binding binding sites and then
regulating genes so they could change by
mutations in the regulatory DNA
themselves so this is the piece of DNA
that this protein is binding and maybe
one of these nucleotides changes and as
a result of that you can lose
transcription factor interactions or you
can get transcription factor
substitutions breaking yet other
transcription factors that that bind
there but the other alternative is that
you can have mutations in the proteins
themselves in the transcription factors
themselves and so the conventional
wisdom though has been that this is
highly detrimental that there are many
player tropic effects and for this so as
an example you have a transcription
factor it regulates all of these genes
if there's a change in this
transcription factor itself then you're
potentially affecting the regulation of
many downstream genes and so for this
reason it's thought that mutations and
transcription factors are largely
limited to the cases where transcription
factors have duplicated and that if you
look at transcription factors across
organisms and focus on orthologues
because of pleiotropic effects you are
going to tend not to see mutations
within them
so there are cases where people have
looked at what happens or have seen what
happens when you have mutations in
transcription factors themselves and so
there are many examples that are
associated with disease and here are
three examples so relating to mutation
and this transcription factor causes
limb deformation mutation and this
transcription factor causes these I
defects and mutations in this
transcription factor causes defects in
growth but those are just case studies
and we'd like to do this a little bit
more systematically so you know we we
noticed you know this is consisted of
the idea that you have these huge
effects that are really detrimental but
maybe we noticed these changes in
transcription factors because they're
they're so severe and in this case
causing disease and so we were
interested in this broader question and
trying to do it kind of at a larger
scale which was do transcription factors
or mutations within them contribute to
regulatory network rewiring if so how
prevalent is this and you could think
about trying to do this experimental II
and I want to say that their limitations
of experimental approaches so for
example to do this we need to look and
you want to do it kind of genomically we
would need to look at many transcription
factors and we need to look across many
organisms as you can say well you know
actually encode and modencode it has
done this but really the existing
experimental data is from a very large
set of diverse model organisms where the
homologous relationships with these
between these transcription factors are
actually hard to pin down are they
orthologs at the duplications is it
something else
and of course if you wanted to do this
do it do it across more organisms you
have issues with scalability and so our
idea was to try to do this
computationally and to develop this
computational pipeline to evaluate
changes in transcription factors which
may lead to regulatory Network rewiring
and so in the general case this seems
like a very hard thing to try to do but
my group has been I guess obsessed with
one particular class of transcription
factors for probably more than a decade
and so one thing is part of many other
things that we do is we study this to
his to zinc finger transcription factors
and so these are the largest class of
DNA binding domains in human and they
have this unique fairly conserved
modular structure where this alpha helix
is what binds in the major groove of DNA
and it's easy to kind of look at this
alpha helix look at the sequence that
underlies these alpha helix ease across
many transcription factors and figure
out the positions of the residues with
respect to how they bind DNA you look at
a sequence logo of the SIS to hist using
finger domain you can say ah this
position is minus 1 it's right before
the start of this this helix so nice
conserved domain and further through
lots of work over decades people have an
idea of what parts of the Alpha helix
are actually responsible for interacting
with DNA and largely driving specificity
so these are unlikely to be the only
things that drive specificity but these
are known to be important so if you look
at a helix and here's one helix but
there are four positions called the
minus 1 2 3 and 6 that largely interact
with DNA and you can see that in fact
most proteins have more than one of
these domains they don't need to but
they often have more than one of these
domains and they essentially bind these
triplets with maybe a fourth contact of
DNA and so from the point of view of
probing variation in these types of
transcription factors we know that
mutations in these lightning bolts
ditions are likely to affect binding
specificity so to say that previously
people have looked at the variation due
and regulatory networks do desist to his
two zinc fingers but they've largely
focused on paralogous transcription
factors and so that's consistent and
they found variation that's consistent
with the paradigm I sit up to begin with
which is you can have variation in
transcription factors but in the case of
duplication and still kind of leaving
this idea that if you look at
ornithologist transcription factors that
you would have these pleiotropic
potentially very damaging effects all
right so we're going to limit ourselves
are in front of your variation and we're
going to do by focusing on the assist to
his two zinc finger and I'd like to say
that I think this is a great system to
look at not because of not just because
of the structural reasons I told you
about and how well defined they are but
really they are the largest class of
transcription factors in metazoans so if
you look at human almost half of the
transcription factors in human are cysts
to his two zinc fingers so we're going
to be looking actually at a at a
significant fraction of transcriptional
regulatory networks so here's the bar
for zinc fingers and here's the other
class of transcription factors in human
is this the number of specific proteins
in all organisms this is just in human
this one's human and so this is I'm at
you're going to talk about fly proteins
and so this type of picture is also true
it's pretty consistent for metazoans in
general yeah yeahs c2h2
they have a lot of fingers right yep all
the fingers the same kind no we'll talk
about that in a second ok so I'll come
back and answer that in a little while
and then you can ask the question again
if i don't answer ok so sewing to say
that these these domains have been
studied extensively so for example
marcus spoke and i don't know if he
showed this picture or not when he gave
his talk and he's nodding his head no so
Marcus is now a faculty member at NYU he
previously was at Princeton which was
which was awesome and one of the things
that he did was he tried to see he
looked at as I said each domain binds
essentially this triplet of DNA and he
looked over all 64 possible triplets and
built these huge protein libraries and
used his bacterial one hybrid system to
assay which proteins could bind each of
these 64 triplets and he created this
massive data set where he ended up
looking at greater than 160,000
interfaces corresponding to 103,000 gila
seas and just if you look to see how
many are distinct with these four
positions that are important for
specificity he was looking at more than
18,000 interfaces corresponding to more
than 8,000 Gila seas and so this data
set was a order of magnitude larger than
all previous data sets combined and so
we have really a lot of information
about zinc-finger determinants for
specificity and what this is meant for
me and my group over the years is that
you can take a transcription factor that
contains the assist to his two zinc
finger domains like zipping axe you have
more than one so there are three domains
here you can identify them you can use
knowledge about the structure you can
use the type of data that Marcus has
generated you could use data that
existed other than that from before and
we have over the years developed these
methods to try to de novo predict the
DNA binding specificity of these of
these proteins and so these methods
don't work perfectly by any stretch of
the imagination but many people have
gone on to use our tool to do some
pretty interesting biology
example implicating proteins involved in
in in recombination as well as in
regulation of retro elements okay so we
now have a system that we can use to
really Pro regulatory Network variation
and that's the assist to his two zinc
fingers and our overall outline is we're
going to uncover and focus on 121
ortholog assist to his two zinc fingers
across closely related species we're
going to see whether there's any
variation and if so we're going to
characterize how much we're going to
really focus on the issue of functional
constraint so say these changes occur
how does it potentially affect the
protein and then because we know things
about the specificity of these
transcription factors we're going to
determine whether the variation that we
observe results in variation predicted
specificities as well so as I mentioned
we actually did this work not in human
but but in fly and so there are at least
12 fully sequenced fly genomes including
the model orgasm drosophila melanogaster
and these organisms last shared an
ancestor 50 million years ago these
flies are fairly diverse you can see
they do they're they're very a lot in
terms of size as well as in pigmentation
and as well in things that they eat and
other things like that so it's a good
system to look at so the first thing we
did was we identified all of these cysts
to his to zinc fingers across all of
these flies as I said these are you know
the largest class of transcription
factors in in metazoans and so we found
hundreds of genes that contain sis to
his to zinc finger domains as EPA asked
about that these domains can occur in
tandem across the sequence for reasons
that hopefully become apparent soon we
actually did our analysis focused on
genes that have more than one domain and
then we characterized ornithologist
relationships between these proteins all
of them in each organism with reference
to Milano gaster
so we asked how many of the for example
DISA shelia zinc finger jeans had a
one-to-one ortholog in drosophila
melanogaster suppose 250 in this case
and this corresponds to a large number
of total zinc finger domains so we're
going to do this analysis of regulatory
Network variation really at a fairly
large scale so covering forty percent or
so of the transcription factors and
covering numerous number of domains as
well so zinc finger domains if you look
at a protein sequence you typically have
many of them and one thing that makes us
a little bit difficult to work on is
that zinc fingers are actually
multifunctional so not all of them bind
DNA but they when they bind DNA they
tend to have a particular relationship
with respect to each other and that
their particular kind of distance along
the protein sequence and we'll refer to
this as being canonically linked and so
there are kind of more precise
definitions than that but this is the
level at which i'll stay in for now and
so these canonically linked domains so
domains that occur you know sequentially
in a particular format with respect to
each other i'm more likely to be DNA
binding okay so we looked at these
thousands of domains and we asked how
much variation do we see in these four
positions that are responsible for DNA
binding specificity and so what you see
here is all the Flies kind of ordered
with evolutionary distance from elana
gaster malena gaster and if you look at
all the domains we can see that the
large fractions of them vary in one of
these for DNA contacting residues that
affect DNA binding specificity and so
when you get to the flies that are
farthest away from the landing guests
are the ones that we studied about a
third of the domains vary in one of
these four positions and thus could
affect DNA binding specificity some of
these domains may not bind DNA so we
restricted this into kind of two groups
we split this up into those that are
canonically linked so they have that
nearby domain
and those that are non canonically
linkedin thought maybe they don't find
DNA or maybe you're less likely to bind
DNA and so you've been just focusing on
canonically linked domains you can see
that a large fraction of them actually
very yeah yeah we used several different
sources of orthologues like ortholog
families so ortho mcl or you know in
paranoid different ones and then we also
did reconciliation so we were really
careful to make sure to exclude things
that had duplications with them do weep
oh no so we actually studied that
separately I'm just not showing that
data so there's also gain and loss of
domains however in fact at least for
flies that's much less common than
actually seeing variation in the
residues themselves so this is the
dominant type of change we see we also
see gain and losses there of course
issues with genome quality so some of
the genomes that are kind of crummy you
might see domain losses more frequently
in the HGC outliers
this is actually at the level of domains
but I want to say that this corresponds
to so seventy percent of the Milano
gaster zinc finger transcription factors
have a domain that shows some variation
and this corresponds over all the ones
that do very correspond overall to about
a quarter of drosophila melanogaster
transcription factors okay so we would
say that actually there is extensive
divergence in one-to-one orthologs okay
so there are these changes but there's
this issue that maybe not all domains
bind DNA and so we spent a lot of time
kind of showing that the positions that
were diverging were under evolutionary
constraint or at other evidence of
functional constraint so here's one type
of analysis where we looked at each
domain and kind of split them up between
the blue which is are the residues that
bind DNA the residues that have nothing
to do with the domain as well as like
for example the linker regions and so we
looked at evolutionary rates and so we
looked at just the positions that
diverged in any one genome and roughly
the signal that we wanted to see was
that the residues that were binding
residues and that varied in this
organism had lower evolutionary rates
than residues that weren't involved in
binding we did the same type of work
looking at populations so here we tried
to ask what percent of diverging
residues are fixed within a population
of drosophila melanogaster and here what
we wanted to see and what we see across
all these organisms across the varying
residues is that the binding residues
tend to be fixed at higher fractions
done the other residues okay we had many
other kinds of tests that were like this
so now we know that actually changes in
these residues are pervasive we have
evidence that these positions are under
functional constraint but does that mean
anything in terms of changes in
specificity so I didn't talk about the
analysis we did of Marcus's data but if
you think about it each domain binds 64
triplets but you have 22 the four
possible
combinations of amino acids that bind
them and he had these huge fraction of
proteins that actually bound DNA so
there's some redundancy so the next
thing we did that is different proteins
can bind can have very similar DNA
binding specificity so the next thing we
did is look through domain by domain and
predict binding specificities for all
variants and so for example here is for
the first five flies they're all the
same and here is a predicted specificity
and then for this domain here is the
predicted specificity and so here's just
an example but we did this kind of more
rigorously and our overall bottom line
is across domains these divergences do
that there are divergences and predicted
specificities and they also increase
with increased evolutionary distance so
then we have these transcription factors
we know they vary we have different
predicted specificities we also want to
see well does this actually change a
topology of the network and so what we
tried to do here was we looked at 52
transcription factors with known binding
specificities in drosophila melanogaster
we map binding sites just proximal to
two genes on promoter regions in
drosophila melanogaster and then we
wanted to know for the conserved group
of transcription factors versus the
diverged group do you lose binding sites
more or less frequently and here we did
many versions of this type of analysis
so here we're restricting ourselves so
we call high confidence binding sites
those that are conserved in the four
closest flies and then we saw what
fraction those binding sites are present
or absent in the conserved groups of
transcription factors in the diverge and
so you can see across the board that for
the diverged set these binding sites are
lost more frequently and that's true at
the level of binding sites and it's also
true at the level of transcription
factor promoter interactions
lost or cross you have mutation after
replaced by some by you as well so we
didn't predict we didn't go look for
like compensatory binding sites so so I
can't answer that question precisely but
so we would say that they're there
certainly well those binding sites are
gone away it's twiddle individual sites
and it's Luke true at the level of
promoters but I think it'd be very
interesting and look to see if there are
compensatory sighs that's what she's
asking and so I think that we don't have
quite the tools to do that I think we
could predict specificities and try to
find them society that after the
follow-up question yeah is the is the
booklet composition to say no to fly and
say like 80 content and I'll observe the
same for some changes um that's a good
question and I think I won't I don't
know the answer well enough to answer
that okay um so I wanted to say that if
you look at the set of conserved
transcription factors and the diverge
set and all both of them together they
actually have different functional
properties overall so both sets if you
look at functional Richmond if things
that are related to transcription if you
look at the transcription factors that
are conserved or dissing fingers that
are conserved you see a lot of
developmental processes come up if you
look at the set that's that's diverged
actually there's no enriched function
but individually these these proteins
are annotated it's not that there are
none of them have annotations so you
know you have things some of them
related with development but largely
because milana gasser has a lot of those
kind of nature's to begin with but
overall there's no biological processes
enriched here another thing we did is we
looked at expression patterns and so the
diverge set I'll say they're expressed
and effect surprising to us they're
actually more broadly expressed when you
look across tissues than the diverse set
than the conserve set but they are
expressed at lower levels and so what I
wanted to argue was that there's in fact
per se pervasive variation and
transcription factors and that we think
this contributes to regulatory Network
evolution and I did this by giving a
comparative genomics framework that uses
aspects about what we know about protein
structure and we showed that there were
changes that could affect Dana binding
specificity we showed that these
divergent residues in a number of
analysis only some of which i showed you
show evidence of functional constraint
we showed that these changes result in
change specificity and this is based on
computational predictors ours and also
kind of consensus based views and this
these changes in specificity actually
increase with distance to millennia
answer and that this gives actually so
instead of thinking about having a
change in a transcription factor leading
the catastrophic changes this actually
gives an evolutionary viable model by
which these regulatory networks can
change okay I wanted to do just one more
short story which was relating to that
was what we did with transcriptional
regulatory Network evolution I wanted to
switch and talk a little bit about
variation other kind of protein
interactions and in particular mutations
affecting protein interactions in
healthy and diseased individuals and
this is the work of dario Guerra see
who's now a professor in Nebraska as I
think this is a picture that sridhar
showed in his first slide yeah yeah
Google exactly that you know we think
about different individuals and we all
all very and again our protein coding
regions are almost the same and so it's
really the networks that vary that that
are different between us that give rise
to this incredible diversity and so as
with the last part of my talk I want to
think about how these networks change
when thinking about mutations and really
just the idea kind of obvious one that
not just for transcription factors were
for other things as well that mutations
that affect protein interactions are
critical under its protein small
molecule protein protein protein peptide
protein DNA protein RNA and so Dario had
developed this framework to think about
mutations with respect to protein
interfaces and so basically
he focused on protein interactions and
he looked at mutations that were
observed he mapped them with respect to
reference and then he was able to look
in the PDB as well as this semi curated
database by OLAP and uncover which
residues are associated with finding and
using kind of very conservative criteria
for transferring information about
binding you can model about twenty-two
percent of human proteins so a fair
fraction but edge I think you can push
this up pretty far and here we ended up
focusing on interactions with nucleic
acids DNA and RNA with small molecules
and also with peptides and kind of
ignoring bigger questions of
protein-protein interactions which have
more complicated interfaces and so the
first thing we tried to think about was
just polymorphic sites across healthy
individuals and so here we asked how
they vary with respect to two protein
interactions so we looked at the number
of sites with structural information we
looked at the number of these sites that
are polymorphic we looked at the number
of sites that are involved with binding
and we looked at the number of
polymorphic sites involved in binding
and this is just restricted to two
missense mutations and if you do this
kind of aggregate this kind of analysis
in aggregate what you see is that
polymorphic sites across humans tend to
avoid binding sites so this is what you
would expect kind of using a hyper
geometric and this is an aggregate the
total number of sites within binding
positions that are polymorphic and so
over all this points to the idea that
networks across individuals which we
know very are not varying due to changes
within proteins and this is you know
maybe what we would expect okay so you
can do the same thing across disease
individuals and so the cancer data set
is a good one to look at here and so if
you look at missense mutations found
across these eight cancer types what you
would see actually is the opposite trend
that just in aggregate you tend to see
cancer missense mutations enriched in
binding sites
if instead of looking at missense
mutations you look at synonymous
mutations which would have no effect on
protein interactions this kind of is as
you would expect and this trend is shown
in aggregate for nucleic acid small
molecule and peptide binding sites but
in fact if you split them up
individually all these same trends are
true okay so then you can turn it around
and this is something that we've thought
about quite a bit now is if we know that
binding sites across healthy populations
tend not to vary but in these cancer
genomes seem to vary maybe we can use
that as a way to try to identify genes
that may play a role in cancer
initiation or progression and you know a
lot of people of course have talked
about this yesterday and many people
raise the point that in fact the real
child that many of the frequently
mutated driver genes have been
identified and the challenges really lie
and identifying less frequently mutated
genes with functional roles in cancers
and so yesterday we talked about using
networks as a framework to do this and
today I'm going to say that structure is
another framework for doing this as well
and so based on the data that we just
showed our hypothesis is that mutations
affecting interactions are more likely
to play functional roles and so we
developed taking kind of a pipeline that
I already presented we decided to try to
uncover specific genes not kind of doing
aggregate analysis where you have
significantly mutated binding sites and
roughly just as just very simply you can
tally up the mutations you see in a gene
across samples and you see how often
binding sites are hit it's a little bit
trickier than that because you have to
take into account more aspects of the
structure but you get some kind of
binding score just very simply here just
adding up the number of binding sites
that are hit across your samples and
then this is just a score to get a
p-value you can do permutations where
you just throw these mutations around
and then you can get a p-value for for
each gene and if you then rank your
genes by p value so from those that are
most significantly hidden their binding
sites to those that are released
and you look to see how often you see
cancer census genes those that have been
implicated to play a role in cancer
initiation or progression you see a
strong enrichment in the most
significantly mutated binding sites if
you repeat this analysis just looking at
synonymous genes somatic mutations you
don't see this enrichment at all okay
and you can do this type of analysis in
aggregate which is what i just showed
but you can also do it individually
across different cancer types and here
is here are genes that were found to be
significantly mutated in one or more of
the cancers and here this part got cut
off but you can see the frequency or the
fraction of samples for which mutations
are found in in binding sites and in red
are known cancer genes as you can see
some cases of course where you see that
there's enrichment in mutations in the
binding site across a broad swath of
cancers and others for example idh1
where you're seeing mutations in just
one of the cancer types and you can look
the see one by one so one of the cancer
no one cancer genes is dieser one and
here's an example of the mutations that
we see in it in red are the ones that
affect an interaction with magnesium
shown here and these are found in
endometrial cancer and glioblastoma and
these mutations affect these negatively
charged amino acids that are required
for catalytic catalytic activity so this
is the type of analysis you could do by
putting mutations that are found across
these cancers onto structures and
uncovering perturbed interaction
interfaces so just to sum this i sum
this up with network variation in
healthy and diseased individuals so I'd
say that networks across healthy
individuals tend not to vary due to
changes in proteins that doesn't mean
that you never see these mutations just
that they are rare on the other hand it
seems that networks and cancer cells
often vary or at least are
preferentially vary due to changes in
proteins and this leads to a way they
can think about predicting genes that
are functionally important in cancers
based on analyzing interactions and so
it for the second part of our talk
what's ongoing is we're extending the
flick ability of this approach using
predicted binding sites and protein
domain information and we think that
using pretty conservative methods we can
get about sixty percent of the human
proteins with respect to interaction
domains so we can probably triple
coverage with respect to the protein
sets that we can look at with respect to
interactions and so with that I'll stop
and thank again dario shilpa and anton
so I mantra usable cuts in TCGA data
expression or translation from CP time
so we have started looking at extra see
whether these mutations are affecting
genes that are expressed yeah we have we
have looked at that it's a little bit
more tricky than we had hoped because I
think the question is when is something
not not not expressed you know so I have
you checked out the emails anything we
have not looked at in dells we have
looked at nonsense mutations but I think
right now what we've mainly focused and
focused on ER or missus
hey Mona so I want from Cornell so we
are also very much interested in looking
at protein-protein interactions and
looking at details of these [ __ ]
criminal actions and you know my
question is more Asafa call about your
first point in your previous slides
about health individuals their network
variation tend not to be due to proteins
changes in proteins because in the sort
of we also the result is definitely
right that is we also observed that
common variants tend to be depleted at
the interface because they're much more
conservative protein-protein interfaces
protein interfaces and but you know the
rare but if you look at the spot you
know based on the Leo frequents the rare
ones do tend to be more engaged and
these protein for ya know and i right
yeah so I know I thought that's right so
I think for like Mendelian diseases some
of those things I think are known also
to affect you know stability but also
interfaces I think just in general that
seems to be true and say we haven't
looked at protein-protein interfaces
because they are more complicated and
you have larger interfaces and so the
effect of a mutation is a little bit
harder to assess because the impact of
the mutation might vary depending on the
size of the interaction interfaces and
so that's why we actually looked at
smaller interaction interfaces here and
so I think it's really you know i think
the ppi work is really cool i think it's
also i think it's also more difficult
yeah yeah i think you just I'm clearly
biased because of my working from I am
do you think although we need to find
more evidence that I think even
for healthy individuals because we you
know each of us carries 45 million you
know based on the ladies the fire very
so yeah so I should be clear we were
relating a protein peptide protein DNA
protein RNA protein small molecule
protein I on and I think and also I
don't want to say that we never saw
variation we did so i just showed
aggregate statistics that said you find
them less often than you would expect
yeah so I guess I have a question so it
looks like you know when you're you're
going at this you kind of approaching it
not so much I mean it's kind of a
network point of view but if you're
going actually a variation question
basically there's fewer new tations in
these type the localized binding sites
do you see that a binding site that
interacts with more things is also like
is there a further selection pressure on
that so is there some sort of pressure
at the network level where's it um
that's a good question and I don't I
don't have an answer for you yeah I
don't know if I think that's a that's it
that's a good question
wow how you define the binding sites ya
say intuitively you've never talked
about like that material / pokey yeah we
have not looked at course so we really
looked at protein ligand interactions
those residues are actually not
including many of them are they are deep
pockets so that's right so so we are
looking at proximity to ligand from
heavy atoms on both sides and so they're
probably other reasonable ways to do the
same thing yeah no we didn't we didn't
know we didn't further analyze that but
the thing with a cork some of the
questions about wheat changes in the
core might also be interesting but maybe
less but I see what you're saying so
you're saying maybe that all the things
that a proximal may not in fact it was
them to have some kind of solvent
excessive um no because I think no but a
lot of times when you look in a pocket
that they are actually they have very
low salt and accessibility some things
have high solvent accessibility and some
things have low self and accessibility
but they're still interacting with the
ligand so right now we're not adding any
extra things on there so it's really
looking at the side chains and the plan
their proximity to the ligands you might
receive
separate into a
which ones more disruptive in cancers
right so we didn't do it specifically on
pockets but we did do it on different
kinds of ligands so for example we know
the signal is actually strong very
strong for DNA DNA binding and for a
small molecule there'll be some studies
that show the cool stories of
uncommitted the season trans changes of
cases transcription factor protein
changes the binding site changes yeah
yes I think you know each step that we
move away move towards / do it would be
with prediction so I feel like the
analysis we did was fairly conservative
and I think we could put you know our
predictions I don't know if I trust them
so well that I'm gonna say you know here
is where they you know really bind and
mrs. the new you know new specific
specificity and here's a new predicted
target having said that I I think well
that in aggregate maybe an analysis like
that could work so I mean I think it'd
be very cool to try we've shied away
from it a little bit
target cross-species the functional
understand in those targets very
different target set is very similar
despite relating different different
species which is kind of and you're
saying sister diverse so not sure those
are the transcription factors themselves
so it's what's known currently about the
transcription factors so we're just
trying to say here is a set of
transcription factors that that are
conserved and some of them are conserved
across all you know their present and
single copy across all 12 flies if we
just look to see what their annotated
with you see a lot of developmental you
know they're in richton and
developmental annotations if i look at
this other set that people had largely
not thought about you know i don't think
the phenomenon was was thought about too
much how much they could vary and you
look at their functional enrichments you
don't see functional enrichments you see
individual transcription factors that
have annotations you just don't see like
a general process that they're involved
let's take one more question and so I
have a question with regards to the
sixty percent proteins you can can
address this at least one binding domain
so do you go beyond if 3d structural
information or what would it be really
in primary sequence page because i know
we use information about structure we're
just we're using protein domain
information as well % is what sixty
percent of proteins have actually
members larger than that if you look at
p fam domains that are in complex with a
ligand and you look to see how many
human protein sequences are covered by
them it's more than sixty percent maybe
it's closer to seventy percent i don't
know the exact number right now but we
need to get from a sink like a pdb
structure we have information about
interaction to kind of a general model
for how this domain
interacts with its ligand and so you are
going to lose some information their
primary sequence coverage oh yeah so
it's not going to be it's not ninety
percent of the sequence that's true for
us already so yeah it's going to be much
it's going to be correspond to the
domain portions of the sequences which
is less so don't have a I don't have a
great number there yeah